these muscles are making you call that a
cogwheel
get down here I need you near that cog
wheel
probably not
so we got a combination of stuff here
and
as soon we're gonna replicate that to
this stuff we just picked up let's do
that
why the [ __ ] up I hope three is enough
I'm sure how many
[ __ ] scared me a little bit
I'm so easily scared
I'll get scared of anything in the same
by now
all right yep three parts let's just
begin with it
slit this up because I don't like going
inside
how it desert mathematically that's not
fun I thought it was a puzzle I need one
more though
it sucks
that made no sense but whatever see if
I'm in the stick maybe I could pick one
of these up that's a bad idea probably
one more I wonder what I didn't have it
went
it's a corner
I don't want to waste my laughing what
all right
okay
in these two rooms
what is this
I am we need a
it's lost part
let's check this just to make sure
and no I am anyway but let's get on
no god damn it some so bad
yeah where is the lost pipe
I want to find a Lhasa fight because I
want to get there laddie what is it
all right about
it when the camera moves for me
yeah I must be in beginning that
is it out there maybe no this can't be
right it's got to be somewhere here
why do I waste oil I have 19 [ __ ]
tender bounces
goddammit
can't move those or is it
annoying
like probably like an obvious spot that
I missed
it's gotta be here somewhere why would
you hide these [ __ ] arts
makes no sense
if there's a muscle to get
or maybe you don't only have those parts
and you have to use a different
combination let's make it work
probably not already been there like a
million times so weird
really weird
so nice and quiet I like that
oh [ __ ] that's too much spinning
make sure I don't miss it
should be here
check these things
it's up
what's up where is it tired of this
[ __ ]
I'm tired I'd hire you does he
yeah good idea
I don't get what I wouldn't crank this
I wonder what I'm gonna do with that
thing
I can't really see what else I needed
for
all right I'm confuse feud is confused
I can resubmit
that like this like that
how do I know which combination it is
No No
how do ice
I guess like this
come on won't work
all right like this then
FAT FAT I tell you
Oh goddamnit
[ __ ]
oh wow
oh nevermind soon I knew that of course
why are you doing what
what I'm not doing anything
my me
don't mind me mr. Alexander brennenburg
I will kick your ass networking
it's stuck let's use the crack
nope
how do I make and
our right
are we all ready to lift things
I'm guessing that's about
can't move lease now
also Skype very very big don't know what
to do
maybe if I jump
[ __ ] hurts my head I don't do that
it's out of ideas again
I like being out of ideas crank for a
machine
crank for my you
Bing something
very cookies
my son
[ __ ]
is it supposed to be like the same
same eye that's one is good
just about to go without one that's good
this one should be down there that
alright let's try that probably never
work support the shot
no they're not even identical what am i
what am i doing
it's so stupid you tie
into the pinkish
just enjoy that
don't mock me for it okay and these
it's not being stuck
stop it
we're doing Daniel
in boxes that's what I'm [ __ ] you
all right
I guess I'm out of ideas
for what I should do dinner really fix
the puzzle over there it's got to be the
song
thank you thank you very much I'd help
absolutely nothing at all
let's take this share with me
ah
wonderful no it doesn't
right
it's like [ __ ]
um
it's not being stuck
it's done very good everything is stuck
in this game
my brain will be soon as well
it's stupid
can't even so they are right I can't
even move
there's obviously something m-miss [ __ ]
you
nope
No
but I mean
I just say it's stuck when it's not out
that
what
then nothing that's
seriously that is his computer
that was a piece of the puzzle just
[ __ ]
okay so we got one side done now
maybe we got Moe I don't know this I
would say it's working
well I guess something
really weird really weird
I have no idea what I just did Oh
did I do that
we
one